[Applause]
all right
happy wednesday everyone
so here's something interesting that
doesn't involve abortion or war
it's a picture of me working out
[Laughter]
kudos to the guys spotting
that reminds me i hope i lock the
basement
so everyone talks about how bad social
media is and yet everyone uses it it's
become the modern version of smoking yes
i gotta quit but right now i just can't
that's me it's the same problem i have
with making brian stelter fat jokes
i can't control myself
just like brian stelter at krispy kreme
see
i don't even know i said that
and i rarely feel better after scrolling
through online stuff and i always tell
people to spend less time doing it yet
there i am late at night sneaking a
social media puff and like smoking it
usually makes my blood pressure go up
now i tell myself that social media is a
harmless drinking partner and that i
have company but i don't have to put out
cheese or crackers
or as msnbc calls it cheese and white
people
however how would i be as a person if i
stopped even for a week
well a new study revealed what could
happen if you stop using social media
you die
i'm kidding you don't die in fact quite
the opposite you live
a new study finds that avoiding social
media platforms for just one week that's
the weekend plus five cat
significantly improves a person's
well-being reducing both anxiety and
depression now if there were a pill that
had the same effect in just one week you
take it
actually i think we used to call those
quaaludes
right degen
but social media
social media isn't something you can
take like the president's teeth at
bedtime it's something you have to
remove
and that's harder
in the study researchers from the
university of bath which is way better
than urinal state college
found that most social media consumers
spend nine hours a week online whether
it's scrolling through instagram
facebook twitter tick tock or my
favorite website mature milfs with club
feet
to find out
what might happen when you cut back
researchers had over 150 people between
the ages of 18 and 72 do just that yeah
even 72 year olds what are they doing
online anybody seen grammy yeah she's
teaching people how to strain pasta
through an old pair of nylons on tick
tock
seen it 17 times
then they compared their normal usage to
a week in which they were online for
three minutes a day which is the same
amount the view spends on researching
stories
and like jessie after his recent hair
transplant disguised as a back surgery
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the results were astonishing
after just one week without social media
there were dramatic improvements in
well-being across the board so why is
this important well social media again
like smoking is something we do almost
without thinking sometimes it's the
first thing we do when we wake up the
last thing we do before we sleep or
right after sex at a truck stop
it really has become a two-pack a day
habit unfiltered and clogging our brains
with tar and selfies
research document documents dozens of
harmful effects from being online
constantly not including the potential
of running into anthony weiner
but there's more to it than that and
it's something overlooked by all the
researchers it's that we humans can only
focus on one thing at a time
go ahead try to hold two thoughts in
your head
i'll wait
see it's impossible but you already knew
that for example one day you could be in
a great mood sun is shining work is
great got plans for the weekend but if
you get a tiff with a spouse it all
disappears it's gone and all you think
about is that one thing that's what
social media does it can introduce one
disturbing thought that muscles
everything else out and that's how it
ruins your day and creates sleepless
nights it could be an abstraction like
an insult from a stranger someone you
don't even know but that's all it takes
social media has created a direct faucet
of aggressive stimuli that we as humans
are not evolved yet to handle our brains
and young brains especially we can't
tell the difference between what's worth
thinking about and what isn't worth
thinking about all you end up doing is
thinking about whatever enters your
mental crawl space last
it's not good so maybe it's time to take
a break especially if just stopping for
one week has such positive benefits why
don't we try it i mean what's the worst
that could happen
you know greg is right for once i'm
wasting time checking things on twitter
and instagram and facebook and only fans
and even
linkedin it's time for me to start
living
[Music]
what
welcome
tonight's guest
he's so sharp gillette wants to
trademark him former white house press
secretary at fox's contributor harry
fleischer
she's so southern she brushes her teeth
with grits fox business anchor digging
mcdowell
[Music]
she believes the grass is always greener
when you sell it to college kids fox's
contributor cat tim
and the fire department calls him when a
cat is stuck in a tree my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champions
[Applause]
ari unlike the rest of us you seem to be
a grown-up you have a suit you have real
jobs do you let certain things enter
your head like you look like i think
people will often lie and say oh i i
don't take anything online seriously oh
i don't i don't read my mentions oh i
don't do but everybody does and then if
there's one thing that gets in your head
it like it crowds out everything out it
pushes all the fun stuff and it's just
this one thought of somebody saying ari
fleischer's a big fat jerk
well first of all and you're not by the
way i was just uh hypothetical
illustrated yes
this is a rental so i need to get
through the show fast cause i gotta get
it back in time um but you know what
having worked at the white house yeah
you really do learn to block stuff out i
like social media i like to look at it
but i really do have the ability to go
this is nonsense this is nonsense this
is nonsense where is the yankee score i
mean they're just some things that are
important and other things you just know
it's people screaming right and i have a
good ability i just give kids
the ability to hear people screaming yes
yes
yes so do you worry about them then on
uh well my kids aren't donna well that's
impossible that's what you think yes
what's your kid what's your kid's first
name
who's right here her fake name yes
no this is just not their thing i mean
they are on it a little bit they look at
stuff but i know that they're not doing
what they shouldn't be doing because i
check
[Laughter]
you don't i don't well look
kudos to them i i just don't believe it
i mean my parents never knew that i had
a stack of playboys under my mattress
until one day they disappeared
didn't see my dad for a week
degan can you like you do you know what
i'm talking about like do you ever look
at social media before you go to bed is
it destructive
no i prefer social media to real life
really yeah yeah reality is way
overrated and i'm not exaggerating
coming to work this morning new york
city i bump into a guy wearing a fuzzy
bear mask riding a bike carrying what
looked like a homemade sword
and on social media i don't run the risk
of actually getting maimed and having
him take like my hand as a souvenir
or on social media
you know what depression is walking
outside and the bright sunlight hitting
the cellulite you know i want to go back
in and hide for days on social media i
can filter these half century old games
they look like they belong to
a dude
a very sexy dude though you don't have
to brush your teeth on social media and
also every baby's cute every baby is
adorable and we all have family and
friends who've had babies that look like
danny devito yeah and you have to laugh
you have to ignore it and just pray that
it grows out of it you know you remind
me i call this the dorian gray effect
that if we get into the world of virtual
media virtual reality everybody is going
to be awesome in virtual reality as they
get bigger and fatter and grosser
because they're not going anywhere so
it'll be like you know the uh it's like
the painting that ages while he stays
normal you know that was just uh an
analogy and i'm just gonna shut up
well that went over well
i just sit here awkwardly we are yeah
[Applause]
don't you understand what i'm talking
about we don't even know who you're
talking to
i'd ask i mean we it's gotten to the
point where you just talk in our
direction and one of us feels it yeah
yeah
you know what you want to take this i
was kind of like i'm going to wait till
it becomes my problem
so
what do you think tyrus
oh there you go
you know what uh unfortunately i agree
with you social media is has become a
bigger monster than anyone can deal with
i can't stand it and uh most of the
people that i know are on it are living
horrible personal lives but their social
media is phenomenal like their pitchers
are always smiling they're always madly
in love and they say things like four
hours since i've seen my husband oh no
what will i do you know and deep down
they haven't spoken weeks in real life
so
so i get it you know what degan says man
it's a great cover but i'm i'm lucky i
have two yeah they're connected twitter
and instagram are connected so i only
have to deal with one and on mine it
says i look at it two hours a week so i
guess i'm winning yeah because i can't
spend with my kids i'm constantly
snatching phones ipads i mean they can
make one out of sticks i mean they've
got to be like the genius behind getting
online and blocking like dad i hope
you're right but i know mine's seven and
i can't leave any electronics she could
turn the microwave into into a social
media outpost like she's always on it
that's amazing you know i've noticed on
these reels these instagram reels the
crazy face
that i'm having such a good time i'm
crazy you know what i'm talking about
yes i do actually you're like look at my
baby
isn't it it's a great baby yeah i'm
going to take it there's all these
different like subsets of that there's
like the you know like single mom but
i'm still really happy face i think is
what most of it is um i don't i think
i'm fi i i think i'm fine with social
media i don't know like it wasn't around
when i was like in high school and
there's a lot of talks about you know
teenagers and instagram making them
massively depressed and i'm sure that if
it was around when i i was in high
school it would instagram would have
made me massively depressed right but it
wasn't so i just had to get massively
depressed about other stuff right
that's actually which is what i would do
anyway that's the point you can't study
teenagers because they're depressed
about everything we do have to be fair
to social media it has improved some
things like being a [ __ ] and a dumb ass
now you're an influencer so i mean
it has changed now you can be a leading
expert on nothing hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else